hi everyone okay continue with another
open language design review for version
13.2
and we are talking about calculus and
algebra
all right
we start at the top I suppose
yeah I think algebra is a big role here
how is that achieved
um so we have a new polynomial engine
that we're using okay so yeah
okay cool and and that means a few I
don't I should have listed it here
there's a few things
that are occasional things that are old
polynomial engine didn't support like I
don't know multivariate factoring
modular factoring.com oh wow we finally
got that that one's been waiting for 30
years maybe we have we have
multi-facturing mod 3 or something yeah
Wowie
hey I've got an application for that
I've been waiting for it to do it for 30
years yeah sure
I'm seriously you are serious I am
absolutely serious two-dimensional
additive cellular automata oh
multivariate again
mod a prime okay well and now you're
quite serious I wasn't being facetious
at all okay
um the uh
that's cool actually okay look at those
um
you know the other thing that's super
important is uh linear algae can I try
this sorry can I try it so if I'd say x
squared plus y to the fourth modulus
Arrow two
hmm
is that right I mean if I tried it in
the previous version
okay so it complained before but it did
I mean I I don't know maybe I can try an
example that has some I don't really
know what would be
that looks non-trivial
yeah I don't know
hmm
how cool very nice
wow that was a long time coming
okay
good stuff all right
the other side is to have a linear
algebra where you have um
uh I mean it's a over a field so
rational functions univariate rational
functions in particular that's
um a common case like transfer functions
transfer functions
by the way can I do this with a an
outbreak number here or a break number
field
okay is it only
um over GF
P or whatever
uh
what do you mean I don't mean a Prime
power field
well first of all I could ask about that
and the second thing I could ask about
is over you know
extension yes yeah you should be able to
do extension
so algebraic yeah so if I say extension
Arrow square root of 2 for example
oh oh maybe not modulus then
yeah
okay I didn't Factor but so what okay
cool all right what else should we look
at with respect to these
so yeah yeah so there's a lot of
benchmarks below there which you see you
know performance numbers basically
um
if you want to open you know like I
would look at the universe rational
polynomial matrices
okay what's this I'll bring this up
shortly okay
polynomial what in a variate polynomial
which one yeah that one for instance you
know and pick something I don't know
debt or something yeah anything you want
so these get to very spectacular speed
UPS pretty early
mm-hmm
so that has some big impacts on on what
you can kind of achieve and do what's
doable
this is exciting I had no idea this was
coming good stuff
that's a good thing
yeah
so so that's that's it so that's that's
huge
um
you know speed UPS you know performance
gains in the whole polynomial sort of
subsystem
um but now what about this what's this
okay so this is so one of the issues
that happens is that let's say that you
want to build um
uh do you want to do polynomial
programming you want to implement
algorithms now up until now polynomials
have been expressions
yeah and that means that you have to
convert them and now you're going to pay
conversion fees in and out so for low
complexity algorithms this is a big
problem this is the same problem we had
with linear algebra when matrices were
Expressions it just cannot work at scale
as opposed to numerical Ray or something
yeah yeah or or even packed a race you
know if you think about that
so I have a question I mean
you know in the modern system we have
this notion of data structure yeah this
General but data structure so one of the
things I mean I think that there's
different kinds of things
I think that what we're talking about I
mean it is a data structure and it could
possibly be published as such too but
that's not particularly useful for end
users because you want it to really work
in the system you know
see I'm saying we have graph graph could
be a data structure but we've made a
whole workflow around it that works yeah
I understand but but look look
okay I understand the idea here this is
a pure function-ish thing that is you
know just evaluates a polynomial
but now for example if I wanted to
factor that polynomial what would I do
it should just Factor it
okay so if I take this
and I say over here
oh I didn't Factor it
yeah the thing is that I think you it's
hard to find a complete list of
operations so
the way it works right now is you have
polymer function apply which is the
other function over there ah yeah yeah
so that that's it I think yeah
we're we're drowning here yeah we're
drowning we'll I'll come back with this
I think right now you go to other
systems when you want to do polynomial
programming then that's what the way
it's going to continue to be until we
solve this well then let's solve it yeah
let's solve it but I just don't think
you've got the right solution here I I
am this came in late I'm happy that we
can take another iteration on it well
look let's let's look at what you have
here for a second okay before we just go
no I mean look come on guys come on
we're not just going to do this thing
where we say oh the design we've had for
the last 30 years isn't quite right
let's just overlay another completely
different design no what are you talking
about well I you know look we haven't
had a design for polynomials I
understand that but the fact well we
have our design for polynomials it's
been General function you know General
expressions
so let's let's okay let's just talk a
little bit about where to go with this
okay
so
this function
just like
you know the concept of this function is
it is a pure function that is
constrained to only represent a
polynomial correct
and it's never going to have feature
creep that it's now representing some
algebraic function or a rational
function or something like that right
right
now just so I understand the the
namespace reservation
you know there could be another thing
called rational function which is a
generalization of this one day
that represents this thing as a rational
function correct
correct we didn't burn that bridge yet
correct okay
so
I hope this thing evaluates its
arguments it does doesn't it
I hope he doesn't uh don't uh not I hope
it does evaluate its arguments correct
if I say
um
you know
don't tell me this is wrong
oh God's freaking sake
you've got to show the freaking
polynomial
well I mean that's another thing that
can work on no we in general we
shouldn't show the polynomial if it's
huge you shouldn't show it but if it's
tiny you should show it well you need to
know that it's not a regular polynomial
like the other ones what do you mean
I'm not saying I'm saying you can show
this but don't just tell me it's degree
two okay I see what you're saying just
show it as x squared minus one you know
it's fine
since you know the variable you know the
variable
I did this thing have the variable in
the in the internal form or not
Devendra can you answer that please yes
it has a variable inside yes
no it doesn't oh uh no it doesn't it
doesn't have the variable so that
comment has the variable it doesn't have
the variable oh
um
no and it doesn't need a variable it
doesn't need the variable but I I'm just
trying to understand the answer does it
have the variable does it not happen no
sorry so yes it doesn't do
okay
so when it displays it's non-trivial
whether it should show it with an X or
something
but probably it should since that's the
most common thing for polynomials
and
so
if I were to take IC so one thing that
is not completely crazy here is if I do
this
oops
and then I say of x
then I am just going to get the nice
polynomial back which is good yes
that that is reasonable
okay
but now the question is
and this is something that for data
structures I consider our solution to be
inadequate
okay like for data structures the way
you find out what you can apply to a
data structure is look in the
documentation
I think it has a discovery interface
doesn't it does it have a discovery
interface if it doesn't it should have
um
oh you can't be serious
you know and this is something Tracy
maybe you can take this that every data
structure should have a
something that you can request of it
that gives you the list of operations
that it supports you see what I'm saying
yep I'll make a note of it
right so so in this case here
we really need that that is you see all
these things capacity copy drop all Etc
et cetera et cetera nuts what's that the
methods yes I mean I consider the way
these methods work to be horrible
okay
and you know I think this is a design we
really need to revisit I I really think
that's horrible I think it should be I
mean it's possible we'll have to
introduce a new syntax for this
um
that is
you know
that for example takes the data
structure you know colon colon the thing
or something of these things here I
don't know exactly what
okay but it's horrible
but now what you've got here
is a different horrifying thing
um
with your polynomial function apply
oh God look at all the stuff
look the real question is
come on you know that we don't do it
that way but anyway never mind you'll
fix that
right
right
the
the real question is a sub-value type
thing or an up value type thing
where you're just doing the direct
factor of this
or something like apply this operation
right
am I making sense
yeah if Andrew can you speak to that
please
right I mean I just yeah I I discussed
it with Adam that you know we should
have the words Adam is on leave right
now and he has some health issues as
well so he's not mathematical yeah yeah
um
so
okay in any case
somehow
I think we have to make this work
well I'm I'm I don't particularly
I wouldn't mind iterating one more time
before we let it loose or we Let it
Loose experimentally
and do another revision right I'm
telling you I think this is the way it
should work I think I think you should
expect see the question is really this
right now if I have a function function
okay and I say you know X Plus whoops I
say X Plus X here okay
I don't know what happens if I say
simplify that
probably nothing
I'm pretty sure nothing
yeah it won't go in
right but so it's an interesting
question
when functions should go inside function
functions
yeah I mean
and it's not obvious to me it has some
bad connotation to calling it function
in a way
um I mean I don't think it necessarily
does because I think that that this is a
meta operation
see I don't think it's bad to in this
case here if simplify had gone inside I
don't think I would have been horrified
by that
oh but there can be side effects I mean
we need a super fast check that it's
side effect free before we do anything
fine but we know the polynomial
functions are side effects free we do
no no in this case we do that's what I'm
saying that this is a much nicer
function than function yes a function
can have side effects yeah I agree
I I personally think you should just
make these functions work on this and
just return another polynomial function
and in the case of coefficient list
right so in the case of coefficient list
you've got
um I don't know what you're doing there
but let's take a look
I see just make it friggin work
just make it work okay so it should
still work for the same number of
functions that it worked is listed over
there but it may not work generally
speaking in the system is that okay what
do you mean like like I mean if like
you've got hundreds of functions which
could act on polymer function yes you
don't need to make all of them work fine
I I really think that that we need to
pull this from this release
um because Adam is not going to be back
for health reasons
um and I really want a chance to work it
through before right okay
all right my my strong suggestion we can
make it experimental but my strong
suggestion is just make these things you
know you give it a polynomial function
it returns a polynomial function unless
it obviously shouldn't like with
coefficient list
right and I don't think there's a
problem with this I think it's very
similar to sparse array you know if I
say you know if I if I say you know
sponsori of you know random integer or
something
you know uh
and then I say you know inverse of that
yeah oh it goes dense well okay if it
was something where this was more
convincingly sparse it would presumably
I don't know inverse doesn't stay sparse
but something that does stay sparse
right if I were to take this you know uh
you know
oops if I were to take that dotted into
in a one zero one zero zero
that still doesn't stay as possible I
don't know but there certainly are
operations where it goes sparse to
sparse definitely right and I and I
think that this is the same type of
thing
now I I admit that there is one thing I
would like to raise
okay
which is I do slightly Wonder just a
suggestion
whether the right oh no this is nice
this polynomial function idea is nice
because you apply it to X and it comes
out
with what you think it should come out
with right
and just like here you'd apply it to you
know
yeah
no I look okay here are my suggestions
number one this should display the
actual polynomial with x's in it
and I wouldn't even bother with this
stuff I would just display polynomial
function of the blob that contains the
polynomial if it's reasonably small if
it isn't small have an illusion which
shows the total size blah blah blah yeah
okay
and and I really wouldn't say degree two
I would just say it's got a freaking x
squared there and if it's degree 300 I
mean this is get much more interesting
when you have degrees hundreds oh I
understand that so I'm saying Roger in
that case what you do is you say
polynomial function of x to the 100 plus
dot dot dot
and you know if it's a giant coefficient
it's some dot dot dot thing there but
you can indicate the degree rather than
rather than sort of in you know
announcing a degree like this I think is
just show the degree
but this is very nice this is great and
I I really don't have a problem with
this if you I just don't believe in this
function I'm sorry I just don't believe
in that I don't think you need it and I
think the only question is what do you
do with a polynomial-ish function that
doesn't operate on a polynomial function
I think you just do nothing just leave
it unevaluated and don't worry about it
yeah I think this was discussed
extensively so I agree there was no
conclusion I agree with you basically
that it's worth but we just want to show
it to make sure that
is discussed yeah I agree
okay fine
um what this will enable
when we have the final design here is
that people can write polynomial
algorithms in top level Mathematica at
speed at efficient which has never been
possible yeah well so let me make a ask
a question about that
um
so if you want to do bit twiddling on
the polynomial
I mean I guess you can just use
coefficient lists to get the
coefficients and then you bit total and
then you put it back into the polynomial
function but it does put a little bit of
pressure on what the internal form of
polynomial function is because it'd be
nice if you could bit twiddle on the
internal form
um
well I it's it's going to have multiple
representations I think okay fine okay
um the other thing I'd like to point out
is you really should make it work with
data structure
and so what you should do is have one of
these because then it can I mean it can
be represented as a data structure I
don't think data structure is sort of
consumer
I mean I take that back they are useful
in the right context if you need it
right but if you need a queue you you
want the whole point is the whole point
is this that what I think you should do
is make sure that this that there is a
polynomial whatever you can be more
detailed than just you know univariate
polynomial function can be a data
structure I see what you're saying yes
you don't have to make it be you know a
super function for the data structure it
can be very specific yeah but the whole
point of that is that but then then you
really can just use compiled code and it
will be you know super machine code
efficient I I'm not sure I mean
why not
uh we're gonna have to do another
implementation then if it's gonna work
with compiler why
because this is not the compiler doesn't
matter it doesn't matter because you can
you can Gateway between this that's all
yeah that's the whole point of what's
been achieved is that there is an expert
struck data yeah yeah no no okay
pyloretics on and it's identical to what
all the other code acts on okay so
there's no transfer you know there's no
conversion
we'll do that it clearly has less
immediate value than this does for no no
I I agree with you but I'm I'm saying
that that is the end of the story of and
then you don't have to write anything
other than top level code because then
if you do need some weird bit twiddling
bit X or you know of the coefficients of
some polynomial blah blah blah then you
can do that using compiled code in a way
that is completely transparent where
you're operating on a polynomial
function here where you're treating that
as a data structure right and moving
that into the compiled code and you know
it'll then be all put together yeah not
bad yes
uh
no one is asking this polynomial
function work with composition if you
compose two of these together yes
function yes yes
um and now so so is it the case if
they're univariates
composition doesn't know anything about
multivariate function really
well that's an interesting point in its
own right because that's about string
diagrams and God knows what else exactly
which is not very interesting in its own
right yes
but but in this case here
shh
oh wowie cool asaurus
okay that's nice
that's nice that that just works
If Only They displayed so I could
understand what they were I'd be in
great shape
um
that's really nice I I really think you
should try to get the scent because I
think it's really close but whatever you
say
um we'll take a crack at it
all right what structured living in
algebra
is that something different that's what
something we started in um in 1301 this
is one more round of it and there will
be at least one one more
these are two new classes of structured
uh matrices
the vandamon and Akashi
so bandaman comes up for interpolation
problems typically
and a Fourier Matrix is for instance a
random on Matrix yeah I've I've used
these in the wild a couple of times in
my life okay
I wish that color wasn't the same as the
color of missing data
or is it that color because that's what
a ray plot does when you give it
symbolic inputs
do you understand I don't know what
uh yeah it looks wrong to me
it does look like it might be that
actually well because because they're
all symbolic right so yeah I know I
think it's an error condition that what
you're seeing there is an error
condition
yes yes I'll check with Diane about it
tomorrow he's the one looking after this
okay
I mean I think if I say array plot of or
Matrix plot of this yeah that's I'm
getting that it's just not right we just
should use a different color we should
map the colors somehow so we're not
giving the error color
for this case yeah that's
I mean some other indication you know
maybe we want a quote symbolic color for
a you know a standardized symbolic color
for array plot right just don't use the
arrow color yes
okay
so I mean presumably if I take this and
I just say
and I just say normal of that yes it
should work yeah okay it's just like a
normal Matrix I mean usual Matrix is
just yeah fine
caution is a generalization of Hilbert
a historically
sorry a historically since Koshi was
before Hilbert yeah right
I meant Hilbert Matrix yeah I understand
um
I I don't yeah great
I think that this is just slowly pouring
out and we'll we'll make a bigger story
of it soonish but it's it needs to get a
little bit bigger what this is and that
needs to be done in a very consistent
way with information and things like
that
yeah we discussed I think we decided not
to go the information we last time
probably
um I think you should also support
information because that's the general
way we're supporting things
I think it can't be done without it
Computing everything at once
there was an issue
um yeah all right week by one we're
gonna have to revisit that
implementation how that's done with
information
fine
okay should we move on that's very
exciting I'm actually very excited about
I had no idea this was coming
cool after 30 years a new engine yep
very nice
is there are there fundamentally new
algorithms or is it just new engine
um both
design for determinant for example for
debt using the new framework um it's
much faster for polynomial entry which
has been a big issue for a long time but
I mean the standard way of factoring
polynomial is you do this Prime you know
you you reduce it mod primes you factor
the integers and then you try and build
it back up with these um if Adam was
here he could answer you specifically
for each and every one probably maybe uh
but we can always look into it but it
actually has a modern makeup of
of fast algorithms so everything that's
kind of happened that's been tested out
yeah
um good it's kind of in this engine
okay
fractional D numerical fractional D well
okay so this is the analog of ND exactly
yes yes
there's nothing notable about it in
terms of design no it's it's what you'd
expect that you have the same notation
as fractional D except the last argument
now as your is the numerical value at
which you want to evaluate that's all
but it works wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
hold just a second so if I say ND
of science you're not handy you don't
have it's in the package well if at all
why don't we have ND it's much harder
but Roger will save it uh it's much
harder we it's been a standard package
and it's no good we need to build an
entirely new one and when we built it we
lost the developer which was Moylan
because he needed to build
TCS
be part of TCS okay but it's kind of
crazy that we have a professional D and
we don't have ND well because the easier
one right we started the easy one and
then go to the more difficult one we
need ND and also n limit for that matter
and then maybe
we don't know oh God that's in a package
as well it's been in the past decade yes
yes yes it's embarrassing yes
all right so we have to say that
embarrassment yeah but I think this is
kind of this is do not be very nice and
straightforward with lots of I mean it's
really why can't I just do maybe I
should just do
um this with with you know that should
that work for sure it won't be as
efficient I guess with what Robertson
might do for sure to look
so if I say d
I see okay
well fine all right so ND is the thing
that's coming we would like to get to
another couple of videos yeah we don't
have a project underway
at this time
okay it will come but but I can't I mean
I can't sort of give a oh okay okay
yes definitely know that we need
okay I have no sense of what's really
happening here I mean you've got
benchmarks here yeah so here's the case
when you have either a single equation
with constant coefficient or a system of
equation linear with constant
coefficients that is it wouldn't
surprise me and if we looked at Wolfram
Alpha data whether that was like 90 you
know a high 90s percent of actual use
cases
so we've made that be both very fast and
also
uh
very high quality in terms of uh the
output
okay can I make a comment about this
because I really drives me crazy
can't you and and
uh
itai resolve whatever it is that you you
know you guys are it is implementing
this and then he says he's gonna do it
and you guys argue and then you come
back to me
so then Tracy this is for you can you
get this in an LCC meeting please to
discuss this and my statement is I think
this should have and I think it may need
some user assistance folk I think it
needs some kind of raft
can do give you to give you an indicate
you know I don't know how to extract
that root object how do I extract the
root object
input form
okay
well how do I extract the polynomial
from this
you I mean there's never been a way to
extract the polynomial you have to do
first and apply it to a variable okay so
I don't like that I think we should have
a way to oh you can do the same thing
here there's never been a way to get it
out I think ever since version three
okay okay so except that it was more
obvious in version three because it
wasn't a two-step thing sure
right so I'm telling you I think it
needs a raft we've got that we've got
that kind of pattern in many other
places yeah there's a raft that comes no
I'm happy to have that discussion but I
want E-Type part of it too too I'm
saying we get dead end you know
deadlocked and it's like do you guys
talk did you agree did it get done and
I'm just chasing tails
so how did this that's impressive but
but um yeah
in the earlier version we're using the
so-called method of variation of
parameters which use the general
solution which has got lots of roots in
it now we do more like a pattern match
to the right hand side we do a linear
system solution like what's called a
method of undetermined coefficients
so it's just a change of the method
being used for this particular college
level class I mean
this will be done by hand in this case
so people asking why can't you do this
by automatically when we can do it by
hand better than you basically you know
so
we are basically translating into linear
equation solving yeah uh you know from
from before it was doing integration now
it's doing linear equation solving yep
right that's nice well done
I mean honestly I think these times
already turn from being kind of you know
a bunch of kind of pigs breakfast type
stuff to something clean is really
pretty valuable I think so too yeah
it just goes to the heart of it yeah
yeah but but I I'm fully I mean I
appreciate your use case and let's get
it worked out
fine
um
and I assume by the way that if I were
to do this with traditional form
I'm going to argue that these might want
to be different in traditional form
and that's another thing that should be
in that LCC discussion right
what's that yeah yeah absolutely
I can imagine doing something can you
add me to that meeting when we have this
discussion but we're going to have the
right people there at that time whoever
was setting up that thing
did you tell someone here to do it Tracy
Tracy Tracy can you make sure that I'm
in there too sure can okay thanks
um
okay
same thing with systems now over there
now if we can get rid of some of these
arbitrary coefficients are we doing that
here
and if so how
I see because we've got an integral here
over K and here we don't have that
integral anymore yes so it's that yeah
so it's like an improvement in the
quality of solutions and well over here
that you're you're not getting any
underweared integrals back in the
solution all because we are not using
the same method as early on
yeah well that's a big win yes so we
uniformly get good results in the cases
where there should be good results
generally you have no guarantee that
you'll get a good result for a
non-homogeneous OD but this is a case
for control systems for in all kinds of
applications that they want this
particular class rational exponential
basically
a polynomial exponential actually yeah
yeah signal processing control all of
these things a zillion things actually
you know mechanical systems this
chemical engineering this class is
d-class
well done
yeah cool
that's
all solution over there is just out of
control and ten times larger yeah yeah
so we get the kind of the optimal one
under the the given but how many more of
these do we have left to go this is the
one for which people are written sorry
lots of people we should do the same
thing for our soul okay it's a constant
coefficient difference equations systems
are different yeah I've noticed that
those can be ugly as well yeah it's the
same story
and we'll we'll apply it there too
good yeah I've I've encountered Horrors
there yep okay Laplace transform well
there's just uh I think uh there may be
some example on the investor plus one
which is much more interesting so
basically we are we are about done I
should have gotten Benchmark we didn't
well there's it's still in uh in a
little bit left over inverse Laplace
transform does have some examples for
the new kind of thing that works now so
do you know do you recognize
oberhettinger the names I do there's an
old book Magnus overhead Sony yes he was
in there he was kind of a junior member
on the Bateman project yes right and
then Mr oberhetinger went on to spend
his whole career on integral transforms
okay fine yeah I mean I know that that
was sort of a so he's kind of the
Pinnacle of what could be done with this
thing called special functions
a pinnacle yeah
you know for for integral transform so
he's that's the kind of what the he's
trying to map it to special functions
and and the goal for this for us here is
to make sure that we for sure is better
than that
for all of these you know
so this is the overheading of uh
handbook
for uh you know Laplace transform so we
want to make sure we're better now
okay
should I be surprised that we can do
this
no
we can do lots of things too
I've noticed but I thought these little
past transforms are a little bit
squiggly
yeah that's not going to work
what well we have this also these other
things called the Bromwich metal stuff
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
so I don't know
so you're already quite powerful what's
required is a small layer of table
lookup on top which will take care of
all the other unintractable cases okay
so why does this not Crush back down you
might don't need to do a trick to expose
one of the experts or maybe I need an
assumption
probably uh assumptions take returns
here maybe that might be one thing
assumptions what degree this is here no
no full simplify have them as second
argument right so yeah you can just put
different assumptions you can just say
whatever your variable is so yeah
greater than zero yeah
uh I guess it should still be the same
as the earlier one it's it's just it's
like a partial fraction kind of thing
sure I want to see if I can get it to
work I mean sure
uh
why isn't it working
I mean why the well let's find out if
it's actually true first right
so you could I think if you give it a
hint like exactly put them together that
might be a little easier
well I'm not I was supposed to go and do
that I was just going to say
um
oh I see just put the numerical value
okay fine I'm just let's see if it's
true yeah
Works a bit unconvincing do you need to
chop maybe I know I need to do a chop
but even even without the wrong side
operated
uh
you know that that
not really the same
so I mean it might not I don't know the
LaPlace transfer members Laplace
transform actually are guaranteed to be
well let's let's just plot the damn
thing so let's say
uh they're not the same
yeah the bug here okay
okay you've got you got this sure sure
yeah okay
okay well it's impressive when it works
okay
right so
asymptotic can now support they can you
can do a full power series because
that's been kind of something that's
useful for a lot of people
why are we calling it so it's the
asymptotic power series is that the idea
yes so given a function your asymptotic
at the Moon Returns a finite
set of like a finite polynomial kind of
things you know if I say asymptotic of
you know n factorial for example uh I
mean if it's if it's analytic yes if
it's not then
uh let's do you want discrete asymptote
right then what you want sorry well
maybe I want to screenshot sometimes but
that would that still make that much so
much sense over here I mean yeah all
right so let me do it with the gamma
function
yes but gamma's is is well it's Union
analytic function first of all
you should be fine
okay let's do it in a non-pole
I don't think it's gonna work I'll
finish it no it's not now oh it uh it's
rather boring yeah well let's let's try
something like this
yeah oh that would look for sure
okay now how do I extract something
reasonable for this
well we could have that in the same
meeting if you want to have that
discussion right yeah right it's another
raftery yeah so this is ugly listen this
isn't even right this is not let's have
that discussion there we are fine but
this has not been designed so I just
want to screenplay I agree with you I
agree with you Steve okay all right okay
okay
um
all right
use case of the asymptotic thing
yeah so here's the thing people come to
us including uh the Wolfram Alpha Team
they want the complete infinite series
and in principle we have it with Sears
coefficient if you use Sears coefficient
comma n you get the N coefficient
it's a symbolic form Yep this is using
the same thing but basically a different
notation why is it called asymptotic
that's what he called it no I know that
I know that but but for the full thing
you know it's usually the asymptotic
well
so what's the difference between this
and a regular power series
well our regular it is a regular policy
here Stephen uh if it was asymptotic I
don't think you could write out the
whole thing it wouldn't make sense
um but this is just a way of getting
a symbolic form of a series and because
because I could as well say
series
which returns a series data object right
that will not work Siri is not designed
at all for infinitely I mean that would
be a huge backward in compatibility if
you try to do that for series because
series is it also has to return this all
kind of it's got all kinds of issues for
doing this yes
wait a minute guys you know I can always
smell it when when there's a when
there's this kind of funkiness look
basic point is this is okay so let's try
doing this
yeah
oh God
oh my God
so basically this is the same except
without
the sort of finite series concept yeah
so one thing
let's go down that discussion now so
asymptotic it gives you an expression
that you can directly use that's a good
feature of it the down feature of
asymptotic return is that may sometimes
reorders things so you don't see what's
the highest order next order because
they really there is an ordering to the
asymptotic series
but that might be mangled when you use
plus because plus is commutative
however in order to design a new ordered
data structure
uh uh we need to
well
we don't know enough to design that yet
of what all the things that need to
contain basically you're saying a new
version of series
no I I so so serious itself serious data
uh is is designed for puso series
univaria puso series basically
and you can have they can be nested
inside of themselves right but it's
univaria too so serious that it's
designed okay and I see we in this
example we see what you're talking about
because here it's something some Big
Blob as a coefficient of Z squared right
here it's been splattered all over
multiple terms
yeah kind of that's at the top level
yeah so we we would like something that
maintains the order in a way from
asymptotic
yeah okay but but you know but but right
now because returning a plain Jane
expression exactly which has some
advantage in that it's easy to integrate
with everything else it has the downside
that it's sort of um
deletes uh you know basically scrambles
to order yeah and it also loses the
Precision information
yes
and so in some future time you know but
but I I would like to also combine this
with designing a multivariate uh you
know series
so it's it's more general order
asymptotics
it's also multivariate that's kind of
when I think it's kind of something to
look forward to yeah this seems like a a
hard to know that it exists Corner case
for now
a little bit I mean but it's it's it's
one of those where in in a way this is
kind of cleaned up
repackaged functionality if you look at
Sears coefficient
uh-huh try a serious coefficient for
that one of those cases
well if I say series coefficient of this
yeah this is going to be harder
but please yeah you know that you can
get any finite series coefficient that's
not a problem
what's more impressive is you have n you
know instead of two having n but that's
not going to going to work with gamma
there
but try to sign for example you already
say all the other cases
gamma is transcendentally Transcendental
and now try the asymptotic and you see
how much cleaner it is because you get
what people would expect from
a power series for sine Z
well but that's just an implementation
problem zero zero n you want Infinity
over there
uh
okay yeah because you want the full one
right so yeah Infinity
yeah
so what's your point I mean this just
looks ugly because we didn't have I mean
this has I times I to the m which is bad
I mean this is badly presented out right
yes that's nothing to do with whether
it's serious coefficient or asymptotic
it's just wrong
this is just this is this is doing the
same thing that you just fixed
beautifully with with linear
differential equations yes
um right so it just turned into minus
one to the n
times you know divided by one plus two n
factorial drop yes that's the most
common case over there as well so we
could improve the risk coefficient as
well it's just a generically series
coefficient is supposed to be a lot more
powerful than trying but improve it
improve it for the cases where you can
improve sure sure
I just one more thing here you can also
generate conditions now so if you got
the geometric series you can say
generate condition goes to true and it
will give you the radius of convergence
as well so that's nice we will Discover
it I mean you should make series
coefficient just work properly sure I
mean is this kind of I think both are
useful I don't disagree with that there
can be improvements to that it's not
super
yeah just use this code I mean in in
those cases yes certainly
okay
onward
like that's so the other thing that we
can now asymptotically solve a
fractional differential equations up
there you probably missed that so
asymptotic diesel got upgraded too
has now a subsystem that can solve
fractional differential equations you
know I should be a consumer about
maybe I will be
I mean it's a big thing for our
multiple physics this business about
fractional dimensional space which is
not quite the same as fractional
differentiation right but perhaps it can
be mapped into that in which case I'll
become a big consumer
um
okay good
I hope these examples are um
kind of
what can I say our
um
uh
have life to them that they're not
somehow some film you should probably
look to the source no they they they
don't have super much life to them um I
think that they're more like recognizing
the variety of fields that they're in
just what I'm saying like this occurs in
probability so that's the way that we're
actually compiling them now we're saying
like you know what are the applications
in probability and statistics
for instance this is the CDF of blah
blah blah
also it's a good way to show that let's
say a federal function also occurs in
fractional calculus so you want some
kind of cross linking between the
different but this is what you added
here this thing here with Ramen and John
yes the blue one and on some cases it's
already in some pages already find lies
are there the blue has gone away
yeah but the idea is to try and fill up
the applications which have been kind of
lacking so far it's been the
documentation was very either I'm not a
big fan of defining n of something here
in document I I mean I guess it's it's
separated by a different context in the
documentation itself yeah yes
so I guess we solved that for a
documentation it's that's not an it's
not going to pollute your system or
anything like that
um Elementary algebra is going into a
study group mode
so that's the the rollout of Elementary
algebra which is from middle school and
up cool okay
is it is it fun
it is I think it's fun and there'll also
be a bit on Mental Math at the very end
to show them how they can use algebra to
do mental math like in a simple
character like 99 1001 is just a plus ba
minus B so but I'm just saying that that
the the for the first students to learn
that there's a resolution that's cool
yeah so we're trying to make the subject
a little bit also trying to show how
what we have got
um in terms of manipulates and all that
so but it's a new audience honestly
we're still learning over there with
Calculus audience was never a problem
we're still starting out
this is cool so one of the things which
I think that we'll be able to finish uh
sometime maybe next year that's maybe a
little bit optimistic but I think that
we'll have the full catalog and there's
two more courses that we want to add
that we think are mainstream service
courses math courses and that's
something one is a course that I'd never
heard of until very recently called
finite math yeah you have yeah I have
heard of that yes okay it's apparent
it's much bigger than I thought you know
then the other one is discrete math
which I know you know about it's for
computer science students so the first
one is for business I'm a little bit
confused because I've heard of finite
math but I wouldn't be able to tell you
it's definition relative to discrete
math well they're totally different have
nothing to do with each other just about
it right well then tell me what finite
matters I don't think I know
I always assumed it was discrete math no
it's for it's basically for economics
and Business Schools too yes so so
discrete methods for computer scientists
basically uh things like recurrences
um you know graphs graphs and networks
will be a very big thing over there
um maybe some set theory uh finite yeah
bullion stuff the kind of thing that we
would regard is discrete math over here
finite math is things like starting
algebra then linear programming uh some
statistics some Markov chains some
Financial mathematics so it is geared to
a totally different audience which is
much yeah so we have around 390 000
people studying or getting for business
every year and uh much smaller number
for other things so business looks like
a very big area for us to cover so and
finite man is a big thing over there
yeah with those two I think that we can
have you know with the things that are
already planned there I think we have a
a com a complete catalog there are other
courses are not service courses they're
for like math departments themselves in
which case we are out the tail and
they're very small courses yep
very good that's very nice
all right anything else we should cover
here nope
okay we hit our time Mark exactly great
yeah good I forgot to work watch the
time well thank you
okay how should we see it there's
another
thing just coming in here okay thank you
okay all right see you all soon bye for
now